I've been in therapy since I was 15
years old and I've had right now I visit
with three different shrinks I've
started the bandwagon I think the whole
bipolar thing is really obviously very
popular now I don't think it's something
to be ashamed of at all if there's
bipolar 1 & 2 so but bipolar 1 is we
could just be mistaken as someone who is
addicted to drugs and alcohol being in
therapy and the electroshock therapy
that you went through which still goes
you get put to sleep for I don't know
about 10 minutes and as you're going to
sleep they put a little it's like a
little piece of film they put one here
here and there's a medication that they
give you now so there's no um there's no
convulsions no but it's really it
actually has really helped I don't have
to take as much medication and it's it's
gotten a really bad rap you know oh the
only way it's shown in films is as a
punishment I would not wish the kind of
drug problem that I had I would not wish
manic depression on someone know the
combination punch of drug addiction
manic impressions is bad I was in there
on a psychotic manic I stayed awake for
five and a half days and I was put as a
result of that on ativan and I got it
that's a benzodiazepine and that's a
very bad addiction I was on that drug
for a year and a half under a doctor's
care to get off of that I had to go into
rehab again I have a daughter now and
I'm not real interested in exposing her
to either one of these illness what
would you even have told your younger
self you know if you could go back you
know I don't think I could have told my
younger self and you know it sort of
like what I helped us get help I mean
really there's not what you know it
learned to say the words I don't know
mean them
you